ancian de nos deux collègues merci
présente c'est juste une petite
réflexion d'abord oui je suis très
heureux de participer à cette délégation
c'est d'abord pour faire mal qui est
fait pour la mission qu'elle a travail
qu'en fait la présidente beaucoup
apprécié les propos de conclusion du
ministre aurait aimé lui dire mais bon
je comprends qu'il ait un agenda et et
qu'ils enchaînent
mais c'est vrai qu'il faut si on veut
progresser il faut qu'on arrête les
clichés il n'y a pas
j'enrage avoir dans l'est dans les
professions les professions de santé
nous en sommes un certain nombre ici
même chez les vétérinaires chez les
pharmaciens il ya plus de 70% de femmes
aujourd'hui qui sortent des écoles
c'est un fait voilà et on va pas
demander à avoir des quotas c'est comme
ça donc il ya des papas qui vont
chercher leurs enfants à l'école
j'aurai cette chance-là ce bonheur là
demain toute la journée puisque je serai
dans mon village
donc voilà il faut pas qu'il faut qu'on
sorte des clichés faucon qu'on rassemble
je crois que c'est comme ça qu'on
arrivera ensemble à faire progresser les
choses grâce notamment au travail ici
que veux tu mènes annick et comme n 7